when I first met my mother she couldn't
pronounce my name my father suggested
that they renamed me
they picked loose which means light if
you googled models student loose editors
picture would come up on the computer
given Lucis background you can Peter
must have faced quite a few challenges
that language barrier the culture shop I
mean you don't pull a kid out of a war
zone and have him turn out like loose
without a lot of help which is why this
is so difficult difficult last week he
wrote a paper in which he argued that
violence was a necessary cleansing force
you teach this I don't know what
something's going on and I want to be in
front of it
she thinks I'm a poster boy like you or
became his tragic past you really don't
like her do you
okay what about a responsibility to tell
the truth you don't conform to what she
wants to suddenly you're the enemy
this woman has some kind of vendetta
against Luce is the chance that what he
wrote is went over your head I can tell
the difference between miscommunication
and provocations like it how about is
something like that might be someone
freaked out you really think I believe
that stuff I don't know
you threatened your teacher I did it
loose
don't lie to me not loose it's the truth
miss Wilson
there were a lot homers this woman
decided to go after him on some
witch-hunt
my home was vandalized I'm not gonna
ruin some kid's life because you come in
here with some hunches sure as hell is
about to be it's like I only get to be a
saint or a monster this will mr. Scott
from mental breakdown he's lying Darius
once you know something
just goes to show you you never really
know what's going on with people
[Music]
you